payer on l'a appris aujourd'hui le
procès clearstream en appel aura
finalement lieu en mai 2011 plutôt une
bonne nouvelle pour dominique de
villepin relaxé en première instance et
qu'il souhaitait que ce deuxième procès
ait lieu le plus vite possible avant
l'élection présidentielle
car l'ancien premier ministre se prépare
déjà pour être candidat en 2012 et hilde
tisse sa toile en multipliant les
déplacements dans le pays
avec toujours comme cible principale
nicolas sarkozy reportage catherine de
bandja et yvon bodin une entrée de stars
devant les étudiants en droit et
sciences politiques de montpellier
dominique de villepin fait un tabac
scène dès sa conférence la france face
aux défis du monde
mais les étudiants s'intéressent aussi
un défi plus personnel ont marqué votre
possible landaise en 2012 a fait venir
consiste d'armand la droite avec deux
candidats sans s'arrêter plus que moi
puisque vous parler d'adieux
est ce que vous êtes sûr que nicolas
sarkozy sera candidat
est ce vous êtes sûr qu'il pourra être
candidat dominique de villepin lui n'est
pas encore officiellement candidat mais
il est déjà en campagne
au rythme de deux déplacements par mois
il parcourt la france sans compter
poignées de mains et bises à l'image de
son mentor jacques chirac son ambition
préparer une alternative pour 2012
sa cible nicolas sarkozy aujourd'hui la
cinquième république
notre république se trouve dans une
impasse
c'est une situation de pouvoir sans
partage de pouvoir absolu
désormais tout se passe à l'elysée
dominique de villepin veut attirer les
déçus du sarkozysme et au delà
rassembler les centristes de tous bords
le pari n'est pas gagné
pourquoi voulez vous qu'un un centriste
se reconnaissent en dominique de
villepin dans la mesure où dominique de
villepin d'une certaine façon incarne
que même cette droite apanage mais aussi
ses droite un peu autoritaire qui
rappelle à mazet gars le gaullisme et
qu'il n'est pas la droite avec laquelle
un centriste se sentira d'emblée en en
sympathique république solidaire est une
organisation encore artisanal lancé en
juin dernier le parti de dominique de
villepin revendique aujourd'hui vingt
mille adhérents
globalement on a des gens qui viennent
de tous horizons politiques de gauche de
droite du centre et avec ces ralliés de
tous bords dominique de villepin espère
constituer un capital électoral
il fait tout pour signer en 2012 son
propre programme présidentiel
de son côté françois fillon